hello my friends before we get started i
want to thank the sponsor of this video
this video is brought to you by
beard lint but there's none today though
thank goodness so that can't hijack the
conversation in the comment section but
it's december so you know what that
means spawn
i guess makes sense to me mortal kombat
11 ultimate came out
been playing a lot more mortal kombat
11. also been playing a lot of spawn i
forgot how much fun
spawn is to play as so i've been on kind
of a spawn kick there's a part of me
that was like i should review the spawn
movie because i've gotten some requests
to do so but
the hbo spawn series i feel like it's
the underdog and so i i want to talk
about it because
though it feels like the underdog of the
two it shouldn't be
so here we go intro yeah yeah i think so
todd mcfarlane spawn or spawn the
animated series as some call it so the
animated series of spawn came out on hbo
in the 90s it came out around the same
time of the movie it was the 90s
spawn craze was everywhere folks if you
had an art class in junior high or high
school at that time
your fellow classmates were drawing
spawn end of story and the story of
spawn in the animated series
movie comic book it's all generally the
same al simmons he's a mercenary gets
killed
his soul goes to hell then the devil
boss mel bull's just like you want to
see your wife wanda again all right well
be a general in my army and you can go
see her al's like sure
so five years later mal bulger sends him
back with the burned up messed up face
it's been five years so wanda's moved on
so he really gets screwed in the deal
which is really cool i saw an interview
back in the day i think the interview
was actually on the spawn vhs in the 90s
but todd mcfarlane was talking about the
hbo series
and getting that green lit and he took
it to a number of studios who were all
like yeah saturday morning cartoon style
sounds good he was like not really what
i'm going for and then hbo
of course being hbo we're like oh hell
murder eviscerations mayhem crime sex
blood
we can do that also if you didn't get
the gist there i will blatantly tell you
right now
this is not an animated series for kids
no this is as
rated r as rated r ever was in animated
form or otherwise sex
murder nudity violence
death do not bring the kids so the
animated series spawn was on hbo for
three seasons which at the beginning of
each episode of the animated series you
have todd mcfarlane there as
kind of this philosophical crypt keeper
but rather than
he's giving you philosophical questions
like what would you do if at the moment
of death
a voice from the darkness offered you
the chance to live again point is in
terms of perception and validity i
thought it was great to have todd
mcfarlane in it and i
i just enjoy the fact that he's there to
spin some philosophical questions for
the episode how they pertain to the
episode and for my money they do a great
job at illustrating the themes of spawn
you know the tragedy of what
spawn is one of the things they do well
is the fact of like well
where does al simmons end and the hell
spawn begin
you know there was something in the
movie when i saw it i was like it just
kind of feels like al simmons comes back
as a hellspawn i guess but he's still al
simmons in the animated series you feel
like this is a hellspawn who was
once al simmons not necessarily the same
it's kind of a theme that i saw in alan
moore's saga of the swamp thing where
it's like at what
point is the fact that you are the
aggregate of the memories of someone at
what point are you
not them though it's actually something
again in the animated series as well as
the movie but i feel like the animated
series really hit it home is the fact
that
spawn digs up the body of al simmons but
right there you're like well
that's the physical body but this is a
physical body that you have
so if there's two separate physical
bodies are you really him i mean
question for the philosophers one could
say oh yes because of the soul but his
memories are so
fragmented he's not really dealing in
the same reality of al
simmons in fact his memories are so
fragmented at first he could be pacing
the hallways of bly manor and that's
what i loved about the animated series
he definitely does feel like a wraith
though he starts peeling back the layers
and remembering who he was as al simmons
more as time goes on but at first he's
just a ball of instinct but i do think
the animated series illustrates
better the fact that he's a hellspawn
who was once a man rather than he's a
man who is now a hellspawn and the
animation style for me totally works it
just
captures that tone of this dark [ __ ]
up
underworld of new york a lot of shadows
in terms of lighting it reminds me of
batman the animated series but the
characters don't have the square
jaw art style of batman the animated
series so i guess it kind of reminds me
of gargoyles
if gargoyles was dragged through the
rated r coles but in terms of animation
style and tone you can totally tell they
wanted to create this cinematic
feeling in animated form which kind of
goes as a
no [ __ ] that's really what animation
usually is or should be but
it doesn't always feel that way you
don't always see that kind of cinematic
effort thrown into an animation but they
really did respond between the horror
movie elements
used when showing spawn dispatch people
and the film noir investigative elements
of people looking into him and
researching these kills
it totally gives this urban legend
methos to the character of spawn i
thought that was a great vibe for the
series but this
mythical hell wraith persona is really
seen from the way some people get
dispatched you know someone's gonna kill
somebody and
you see those chains in the cape come
out of the darkness just wrap around
someone and suck them in it kind of
reminds me of batman begins though i
should say batman begins reminds me of
spawn since spawn came out before batman
begins do you know that scene where he's
just sucking people into the shadows
imagine that
but it's those chains from spawn's
outfit and the cape
and they suck them in and then you see
compound fractures and death and we
cannot talk about spawn without talking
about keith david's voice
as spawn keith david at this point was
no stranger to voice animation means the
voice of goliath and gargoyles also he
is
the voice of spawn for people who've
watched the hbo series
he spawned keith david as the voice of
spawn is quite frankly and quite
simply perfect he's perfect because he
has that voice that lends itself to
being that
sense of security and compassion for the
flashback scenes with him and wanda when
he's human and also the voice of a
hellspawn the dude just has that voice
that can be either this is also why
it's amazing they got keith david the
voice spawn in mortal kombat 11. not
only does it add validity to the fact
it's like oh yeah he's the voice of
spawn and he's spawning here but
i'm glad that keith david's just he's
it's not like he's done with spawn which
gives me hope for the future
which i'll talk about in a second hey
one can hope it's free to hope there
were a couple
things in this series that left me
wanting first of all
clown in seasons one and two he's there
and
the clown's kind of the babysitter for a
new hell spawn
so he's there around spawn he pops up
every once in a while
taunts him talk some [ __ ] unlike john
leguizamo in the movie spawn like john
leguizamo
in spawn the movie was the comic relief
i think he did a
great job as clown in the spawn movie in
fact
he's a standout and john leguizamo
remains one of the most underrated
actors working but the movie spawn was
still
pg-13 so that comic relief was there to
kind of
lighten the mood and keep it pg-13 for
the rating system
i imagine in the hbo series clown is
just a [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's a real son of a [ __ ] which
i think represents a demon of hell more
accurately like
if there is a hell i imagine someone
who's from hell a demon from hell
is probably more along the lines of
clown from the animated series spawn
than you know the funny clown from the
movie but in seasons one and two clown
was there to taunt spawn nip at his
heels a bit
show up uninvited in season three he's
just his absence is very much felt and i
don't know if clown's absence in season
three was because they were like oh
we're kind of on the verge of getting
cancelled so we got to throw a lot of
stuff at the wall and hopefully it
sticks and we gotta move things forward
faster so season three delves more into
the fact that
hell has soldiers on earth but so does
heaven and they're clashing
but this hell spawn doesn't seem to be a
complete and total [ __ ] so there's
conflict there which takes us back to
season one of spawn
in which in one episode they introduced
the character angela
and they just she's never in the series
again that is something that sticks out
like a sore thumb you can't help but be
like
why was she even in it if they're not
gonna have her back so glad they delved
into
what it looked like that set up which is
the fact that there are
heaven soldiers as well as hell soldiers
but it's weird that she was even touched
on if they
didn't show her again the only thing i
can think of is a licensing issue of
some sort i believe neil gaiman wrote
her arc so i don't know if like neil
gaiman is like no no that's my character
i don't know which brings me to the fact
and the point yes
it was cancelled and you feel it it's
not like it was cancelled but they got
to wrap it up it ends like all right
i want to get my soul back done oh
canceled the end
all right [ __ ] and todd mcfarlane's been
trying to get a new
live-action spawn movie made when you
hear him talk about it it sounds like he
essentially
wants a spawn movie to be in line with
the spawn hbo animation but live action
version in which case if given the
choice of
having a new live-action spawn where
he's like all right start from scratch
and you see the spawn story again
or just picking up a season four of the
animated series
something that we already have three
seasons of build-up i would take a
season for the animated series
i mean shoot i suppose we don't have to
have one or the other we could have both
i mean i'm not going to speak for keith
david but
he voiced spawn in mk11 it doesn't seem
like he's done with the character and as
we've seen lately an animated series
that was cancelled decades before
it can come back yeah weird is that
animaniacs
speaking of which spawn but i'm just
saying it's possible and the point of
all this is i think the hbo spawn
series is worth a watch for you it's not
the fantasy sci-fi
spawn going on a rampage romp that maybe
you want maybe that's what you like
about the movie if the spawn movie
always made you feel like
it was missing something we shoot i
enjoy the spawn movie and that guilty
pleasure kind of way
i do you know how many times i'll be
playing mortal kombat 11 using spawn if
i'm getting my ass kicked
i audibly say out loud you sharama but
if given the subject matter of
spawn the movie made you feel like it
was missing something like they could
have gone
deeper with some of the themes check out
the hbo animated series you might find
what you're looking for there i mean the
dvd of the entire series is 12
bucks on amazon it's not that expensive
i would like to see a blu-ray release
absolutely i hope they do that but the
fact that they haven't
again shows that maybe there's not much
interest in reviving this series but i
do think the series is worth a
conclusion
um one can hope all right so todd
mcfarlane spawn or spawn
the animated series have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you